the last episode of marvel's loki took
on a surprising thoughtful look
at the problem of opposites
of course the entire series was about
the challenges and opportunities of two
extremes unlimited variability on one
side and absolute control and linearity
on the other and this whole problem of
course culminates into the last episode
but to my own surprise was brought into
an almost theological realm as the
entire climax of the series became a
play on adam and eve in the garden of
eden facing the puzzle of the serpent
so we will explore the final episode and
just the general tendency in both the
mcu and dc to move towards this trope of
the multiverse in their storytelling
just a warning this video will contain
an infinite amount of spoilers by the
way
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
the loki series is of course one of the
assets setting up marvel's face four
story layout of which one of the major
themes seems to be the exploration of
the multiverse idea here the adam and
eve motif in the loki series which
appears for all intents and purposes at
the genesis of this multiverse in the
mcu is certainly not something which is
accidental the multiverse idea or the
notion of an infinite variability on
identities is one which has been
explored both by marvel and dc in their
comics long ago and even in some recent
movies for example the the spider enter
into the spider-verse movie uh for
example but this now takes an
increasingly important role in the
social narrative which is itself
obsessed with difference and variation
and so is being taken to the next level
in these franchises so both marvel and
dc
seem to be set on diving into this
multiverse notion in their next slew of
projects though creating this vision not
only within their stories where we
discover the clashing of infinite
universes which contain infinite
versions of every character or event but
also creating something like a meta
version of this concept in which all of
the previous movie iterations of batman
or spider-man for example were simply a
glimpse into this multiverse of
variability all along so marvel is
actually taking this one step even
further what they're doing is they're
introducing this multiverse idea through
a multitude of means and disconnected
stories first we saw this as faints
actual faints and the last spider-man
movie for example or in one division and
now we see that as an explosion in loki
as this cosmic mistake in the next
spider-man movie and just as a basic
question on variation in the recent what
if series so the loki series presents
its own take on the multiverse starting
first with the vision of a tyrannical
and bureaucratic system of control the
tva or time variance authority watches
the quote sacred timeline for breaks the
breaks can happen anywhere and at any
time and so the tva can travel to any
point in time and any part of reality
these breaks are caused by variance
variants which spawn entirely new
timelines and theoretically entirely
distinct universes which are rapidly
pruned by the tva in order to preserve
the unity of the timeline prevent chaos
which would ultimately lead to a war
between the different timelines as they
one day become aware of each other
through a character
named he who remains that we'll look at
a little later so in the series a
variant of loki is the main character at
the outset though like so many
franchises these days the spotlight and
narrative arc will gradually shift to
another variant of loki a female version
named sylvie usually these variants are
pruned with their timelines but these
two loki's through their usual trickster
characteristics succeed in avoiding this
and ultimately they team up to find out
what is at the source of the tva and
with a plan to destroy it or maybe take
over in the usual loki style sylvie
interestingly enough has been able to
avoid detection from the tva by hiding
and living at the end of different
worlds at the edge of cataclysms where
all will die the two loki's even in the
series fall in love at some point an
event which is deemed extremely
dangerous for the timeline but also
seems to us narcissistic and
a little more than unnatural but we will
later understand what this is about in
the final episode of the series so in
this final episode both the loki's go to
the very end of everything the end of
time and space we could say where all
these prune variants are sent to be
devoured by a cosmic void monster named
eliath passing this cosmic death both
loki's find this medieval looking castle
in which lives he who remains all of
this is set up like a kind of ritual or
initiation where they have to go past
this monstrous guardian and then upon
entering the castle they're offered a
test
something both loki's would desperately
want
in exchange for them leaving though they
remain untempted after that they meet he
who remains and the first hint of a
biblical reference is of course this
character introduces himself to them
while eating an apple he takes both the
loki's up an elevator to his office at
the very top of the highest tower the
top of the mountain we could say brings
them into paradise he who remains or the
remainder we could call him explains the
story in his own life on earth he became
a kind of bridge between worlds that is
a variant of himself was a scientist who
discovered that there were infinite
universes stacked on each other with
infinite variance of everything that
existed the different variations of
himself started to communicate with each
other at first helping each other but
because they were infinite versions of
themselves and in infinite universes of
course some of these variations were
dangerous and one and only to conquer
the other universes this led to a
multiverse war where entire realities
began to attack each other so this
particular variant the one in the loki
series discovered a monster
a monster which was made from the very
tares in reality and this monster
devoured time and space
and so it was weaponized by he who
remains to isolate a single continuous
timeline and end the multiversal war so
it's first off very interesting to see a
few of the images that are being played
out in in this narrative to begin with
he who remains is already an interesting
notion in himself a kind of remainder of
the process of history an anomaly which
does not fit into the story who is
somehow outside the story and because of
that this remainder was able to bridge
different realities a kind of
shape-shifter and not a shape-shifter in
his own person but in the very
possibility of his being being stretched
out into infinite variation so bridges
are of course always in between spaces
there are always these remainders that
are in between two identities and are
very ambiguous for on them can cross of
course traitors and scholars but also
armies and weapons the remainder or the
undefined can both guard a treasure or
devour you and this is related to the
numerous stories of monsters guarding
treasures or mysteries of some sort now
of course he who remains is akin to the
serpent in the garden of eden both as he
is presented in the story but also in
his role for the serpent is also
something like the remainder that is
this twisty shape shifter which appears
on the edge of a coherent identity the
reminder that any system is never
perfect and fully contained i mean we
often wonder why the serpent is in the
garden in the first place if this garden
is supposed to be paradise in loki this
cosmic creature goliath the void monster
made from the tares in reality is in
many ways a version of this remainder as
well an extension of he who remains
similar to how the cosmic leviathan in
the bible story is an extension of the
serpent in the garden and so he who
remains is both a kind of anomaly and a
bridge between worlds but ultimately
becomes the tyrant over reality we
already see how he embodies two extremes
in his own person the two extremes of
the edge we could call it so in this
guise he who remains he presents the two
loki's between with a choice between two
extreme so it's not exactly good and
evil like in the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil in the genesis account
but it is very similar he presents them
with the option of stifling order or
cataclysmic chaos that is either the two
loki's become the new tyrants and
continue to maintain a single sacred
time by killing all the variants a
timeline where all is already known and
of course just playing itself out or
else they kill he who remains and let
the timeline split into infinite
variation which will ultimately lead to
a multiverse war once again and so this
gambit these opposites can be seen
through several positive and negative
angles which are actually explored in
this final episode not only through the
loki's but also through secondary
characters like mobius and ravona
rensslayer these opposites appear as
free will versus fate and kind of
predestination accepting a lie to
preserve an institution versus exposing
the truth and risking total chaos in the
case of the loki's it is important to
understand how they become an image of
adam and eve because they are two sides
of a single being
like eve was taken from the side of adam
these two are also a male and female
variation on loki in this case we can
understand the conflict and love between
them as a primordial situation which
also echoes the capacity of our own
different parts as a single person your
thoughts in your body or your rational
and your emotional side however you want
to frame it your different parts to be
able to unite these different opposites
and unite the fragmentations within you
into one so the serpent of course finds
pleasure in dividing them making them
believe that there are only two options
the two extremes of reality either
absolute tyranny or anarchy and chaos he
pits them up against themselves as
opposites saying for example that loki
is one who cannot be trusted and silvi
is one who cannot trust
and even in their exchanges loki
presents himself as the one who wants to
wait and reason things out and sylvie as
the one who wants to act before the
opportunity is gone and so they are at
an impasse then i guess we're in a
pickle
so we wait
wait
the impasse is of course bound up in the
dualism presented to them from the
outset the same duality we see in
politics in popular discourse this
slavery to extremes and to irreducible
opposites which in the christian terms
is called the world of the fall this is
the manichaean world of absolute inside
outside male female control freedom and
so many other opposites in which balance
and middle road cannot exist now of
course the solution to the problem is
actually hidden in the story not made
explicit or detailed but hinted at in
the character of the loki's the solution
to the opposites is something like faith
and love you see if only they could
surmount their own selves their own
idiosyncratic fears and desire and
rather trust each other so the solution
is to trust but also to love and not
love in the kind of sentimental idea we
have of it but
love in how these two variants of loki
could be united together into one
without eliminating their variability in
this frame the possible love between
loki and silvi no longer seems to be so
weird and unnatural but rather becomes
an image of how unity and multiplicity
can coexist without either eliminating
variance indifference or
falling into a mire of chaos and
conflict so the solution to the problem
posed by he who remains is trust and
love but just like in the garden of eden
our protagonists rather fall into
blaming into mistrust and blinding
desire so surprisingly enough here as
well like in the garden of eden it is
the eve character which consummates the
act and murders he who remains sending
the world into both an insane chaos of
variance and a subjugation to the
tyrannical variants of he who remains so
the series of course ends on a
cliffhanger where loki has been
forgotten by his friends and so is set
back adrift in a world where he does not
belong a world that does not recognize
him a world where hope is lost and so in
the end despite all its faults the loki
series presents an interesting play on
the very ancient story of the fall and
its consequences as a pendulum swing
between the extremes of tyranny and
chaos both in society and in our own
cells but in general we need to be
attentive to the multiverse story arc in
these upcoming projects as they will
also engage in this duality and it is
difficult to know at this point they
will continue to promote anarchy
revolution and the supremacy of desire
as we have seen dominate in cultural
production since at least the 1960s or
rather if they will use this multiverse
narrative as a call for safety call for
control and uniformity a call to eject
variants and scapegoats reflecting the
clear new direction in which our culture
is appearing on our horizon at this very
moment hopefully they would be able to
find that middle ground we all desire
but sadly it might be too late for that
at this time
so i hope you enjoyed our heavy metal
variation on the symbolic world opening
it was made by a band called skies turn
black
and so make sure you subscribe and share
and do all the things that youtubers ask
you to do but also check out the
symbolicworld.com
where you will find all kinds of ways to
get involved in this symbolic thinking
you'll also find there a way to support
this work financially if that interests
you supporters get an extra video a
month and a lot of other possibilities
as well so everybody thank you for your
support thank you for your time and
attention and i'll talk to you very soon
[Music]
you